政治して行ってきました富山県に戻ってこのちゃんの事務所としてるってだけトレから
[音楽]
倒すかこれ
ばツアーん
まーりお
[音楽]
形を
中学校の人たちとは久しぶりに会って次な気分でした
全然話せない人とバーン
[音楽]
いろんな人がいてなんかすらないんですけどすっごいいろんな人にいい
飾り冊 youtube
してるでしょああ
外れるか用チューブしてるあの
あの3みたい私あのまだ十条する道に寄ったんだ
まぁなんと1分おっ
パピバックキュッキュッすごいいろんな人に
僕はあまりテレビせよ2学校の一つ
すごいなどいろんな人が見てて
すごいなんか体中に戦慄が走りましたね
油井昌今の見てで成人式で俺にあった人立つ
チャンネル登録と高評価してくださいみんなに言えることは
まだせいぜいしていけない人知らない人もあんまり話したことない人もいるし
なんかん
あんまり行きたくないなぁと思う人は絶対行ってください
行ったら変わりますもう行ったらな八かやってと楽しいんだよ
みんなすごい久しぶりにあってきっともっとテンションおかしいんで
楽しめると思うんでまた声優陣して言ってないとぜひ
行ってみてください
楽しいと思います絶対
一定損はないと思います
雨を成人してる人はもうサヨナラ
12年
邪魔から帰ってきたんで
ましたら
通常営業いたします
まず政治意識たほうがいいよアートと可能
じゃあな
おっ
ni